Well,
think of reward as what happens with you
achieved something,
but that's not exactly right.
Not with human beings.
Most of the time we feel reward when or
so engagement and,
and,
and positive the positive desire to move
forward in life when there's evidence
that we're moving towards a valuable
goal.
So we're making progress.
It's like,
yes,
we're making progress.
There's a real neurochemical kick that
comes along with that.
The same system that cocaine effects and
amphetamines.
And so with rats for example,
you can get wrapped hooked on cocaine if
they're alone in a cage and they'll self
administer cocaine until basically until
they die.
But if they're doing rat things with the
route buddies,
like they're not that interested in
cocaine.
So,
so,
and the reason I'm saying that is
because like a rat who's out with his
rat buddies doing rat things gets enough
reward from that.
So the drugs aren't that attractive.
So part of the reason that people take
drugs like cocaine is because they're
not doing enough things that are deeply
meaningful,
you know?
And so,
but you don't get meaning unless he got
a name because you're.
Your nervous system is wired to give you
a pat on the back when you're making
progress towards your aim.
Well,
so you've got to have an aim and the aim
should be high because otherwise why
bother with it,
but it should also be broken down into
steps that you have a reasonably high
probability of attaining.
You know,
with a kid you want to say,
well,
you're trying to get your kid to develop
you.
You don't give them an impossible task.
You give them a task that's slightly
harder than that,
which they can already do.
Right?
And so they're engaged by that.
Maybe they're a little anxious about it,
but they master it and they've.
They've expanded their domain of
competence.
It's no game.
It's a big deal to do that and that kids
love that,
that that's where you learn in that
zone.
You know where you're pushing yourself
just a little bit beyond where you are.